with John 2 you know he's talking about
maybe one left he goes if Francis came
back great and they're like yeah what
about Sergey Pavlich you know and he's
like I'm good you could make a case that
the pavlovich fight is a better fight
just on pure hardcore fight terms there
is plenty of natural fight Intrigue in
seeing John fight Sergey pavlovich but
from a marketing standpoint I don't know
what the it gets you and people
were saying oh do huge on pay-per-view
his Q rating here pebblevitch is very
low he just fought in the Apex like he
doesn't have a whole lot of of a fan
base built here in Russia their ufcs are
not sold on pay-per-view it's part of
your basic cable package over there so
that wouldn't do you any good and a
hello he can knock your head into the
bleachers with his power and what are
you going to get from the pay-per-view
sales which are tied to your pay why the
would you take that fight if you
don't have to it's such a good point it
makes zero sense for John